hi i'm maria i'm a tasty producer today
i've been challenged to take a common
holiday food and make it fancy let's see
what we are making fancy today drum
rolls
candy canes
i have had this before i'm not big fan
of candy canes it kind of tastes like
cough drop but doesn't give you any
benefit of cough drop i've seen candy
canes used as stocking stuffers i've
received it before would you gift
someone candy canes
no it's been a long time since i tried
candy cane so let's give it a try
it's pretty it doesn't look like candy
it doesn't look like something you can
eat it look fancy it's cute it's not
round but it's cute snaps well i like
mint but i don't like mint in a candy
it's not as bad as i remember it is kind
of colorful and pretty is there a
recipe on the back
yes
creamy candy cane cocoa is that what
you're going to make today no
i'm not 100 sure what to do with this
but i do have some ideas so it's going
to be very ambitious but it's a holiday
season there will be a holiday magic so
as always i'm excited to make it fancy
all right here's what i got taco needs
heavy cream cream of tartar condensed
milk sugar pearls sprinkles butter eggs
chocolate stirs and chocolate ice cream
from the pantry i got flour sugar salt
cocoa powder food coloring espresso
powder peppermint extract canola oil
vanilla extract guinness peppermint
schnapps and spiced rum triple alcohol
all right let's get started
[Music]
so go
make it fancy
first i'm going to process candy cane
i'm using full box of kind of thing so
it's about 12
rough chops
using the sieve so you can just get like
nice big chunks i'm gonna set this aside
whip some cream add two and a half cup
of heavy cream 14 also condensed milk
with this
this is a great technique for making ice
cream it's no char ice cream so if you
don't have ice cream machine you can
definitely use this method at home
because it's holiday
every day is a holiday for me then
peppermint schnapps
one tablespoon and peppermint extract
one tablespoon
and adding two
or three drops of watercolor i'm using
food color gel because it incorporates
better you want to whip until soft peak
add candy cane fold into the ice cream
mix kind of clears my sinus
it smells very pepperminty this looks
good covered with plastic and freeze
this at least four hours to overnight
this is first time we are doing craft
time for making fancy so we have poster
board and parchment paper
and i'm going to glue parchment paper to
the poster board i'm not a crafty person
so
i hope this turns out okay this is kind
of already ambitious right
so i'm folding in one side of the edge
into the other edge and making a corn
shape you want to make sure the bottom
is nice and tight and using the tape
secure so it doesn't fall apart this is
a little too big so i want to cut about
three inch and use the tape and seal the
bottom put in a container i have
chocolate ice cream softened packed this
corn with chocolate ice cream about
three fourths of the corn
and using spatula you're kind of
hollowing out and make a hole about six
inch thick so this looks good and i'm
going to freeze this for 30 minutes i
have 3 4 cup of all-purpose flour 1 4
cup of cocoa powder half teaspoon of
espresso powder quarter teaspoon of salt
just gently
mix it
and we're gonna work on the wet
ingredients we have 2 eggs 3 4 cup of
sugar
half teaspoon of vanilla quarter cup of
canola oil and then mix them well
driving on the highway highway watch
2021. you want to mix until sugar is
dissolved and it's become a little bit
pale color add dry ingredients
and then mix them well
and you're going to add 2 tbsp of melted
butter quarter cup of guinness and
combine well the style kind of gives
nice rich flavor but if you don't want
to use alcohol you can use
coffee
one half cup of coconut if you are
watching
make it fancy from the beginning i love
using cacao nibs because it
it's not sweet it kind of gives nice
bitterness
so again i think it
gives a nice adult flavor add in quarter
cup crushed candy cane this gives nice
texture as well
i have seven inch round cake pan and i
already lined with parchment paper on
the bottom and i sprayed two cup
parchment paper
spray
one more
spray
i'm doing this because it is easier to
take it out after you baked add the
butter to the mold so we are going to
bake
350 fahrenheit 25 to 30 minutes and
let's move on to next step follow the
chocolate ice cream corn i have
peppermint ice cream that we made
earlier fill
this ice cream inside of the corn once
the whole is filled you're going to
add more ice cream on the base
it's a good dessert to make
for winter because this could be
disaster when you're making in the
summertime feel ice cream nice and tight
this is a brownie from earlier it's
already cooled would you say you're out
of your comfort zone always
adding brownie
and press to the ice cream and it should
be nice and tight this has to be chilled
in the freezer at least eight hours
preferably overnight but we have a
professional freezer so it will be
faster for us so i'm going to freeze
this and move on so i have two cup of
sugar two candy canes broken up and one
cup of water
and bring this to a boil
give it a little stir but once it's
boiled you don't want to touch it
because if you move around it might
crystallize sugar is very interesting
ingredient sugar is very fascinating
next to eggs while we are waiting i'm
going to whip egg whites i have eight
egg whites one teaspoon of cream of
tartar
[Music]
so candy cane is melting we reach to 240
and syrup is looking good i'm adding
steady stream of hot syrup to our
meringue and this technique is called
italian meringue so you have to
constantly whip this
in a stand mixer in high speed until the
meringue is stiff peak and grossly about
six to eight minutes so i have one
tablespoon spiced rum and whisk again
i'm going to put them in a piping bag
you want to twist the piping bag and
push inside of the tip so it doesn't
leak i have filled my piping bag and i
have plenty more italian meringue i'm
going to bring rest of the item we have
reached ice cream corn take the tape
off i'm taking off the paper it is kind
of stuck
and i don't want to destroy the shape
so being very gentle
so i'm going to start piping meringue i
think this looks great like everything
is handle made like we also made a mold
it's so far just as i imagined
and when you are piping
make sure to pipe on
your dominant hand i start it from the
bottom and move toward to the top and
you have to move fast because it's ice
cream it melts
meaning tower of christmas tree i made
snow covered christmas tree and now time
to use my secret weapon i'm gonna start
torch i want to make this meringue brown
nice toasty color you want to make sure
you have a little bit distance you don't
want to torch too close so the meringue
will burn you might have a little bit
smoke that's okay as long as it doesn't
catch on fire i want to make sure toast
everything and doesn't have any bold spa
so when it's done it looks like white
and brown
right looks great
i'm going to decorate my christmas tree
i have a few 3d christmas cake
decorations i have sugar pearls mini
candy cane and star shaped chocolate so
just start decorating kind of like
filling the
gap as well
i got some green one i got some red one
i almost feel like decorating a real
christmas tree with ornaments and i have
candy cane kind of sticks in and doesn't
move it looks really cool final touch i
have star-shaped
chocolate and we are done
[Music]
baked alaska christmas tree very fancy
i'm so excited to eat it but it's almost
too pretty to eat almost but sometimes
you have to destroy your own creation
i'm gonna just go for
a bite it's almost like dripping a hole
[Music]
it tastes like a holiday i still taste
candy cane but it's very elevated
peppermint schnapps and spiced one it's
very good brownie has a nice crunch with
coconuts it is nice chocolate and mint
harmony overall i'm so happy how it
turned out it looks very festive it just
looks like christmas tree that you can
eat thank you so much for watching i
challenge you to make a home when you
make it please tag me on instagram and
don't forget to dance make it fancy and
happy holidays
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so